[Musique]
alors bon à mon avis comme on pouvait le
voir on a vraiment des moyens
exceptionnels sur scène on avait une
petite en beauce
valérie bénaïm vous m'aviez défier sur
slam l'émission de cyril tout à fait
c'est quoi l'histoire alors qu'est ce
qui se passait écoutez vous avez fait un
peu le malin lors d'une précédente
émission bien sûr parce que vous disiez
être un homme de lettres je vais vous
est pris au mot vous visez vous étiez
cruciverbiste bien sûr vous adoriez les
mots croisés tu sais j'ai voulu savoir
si une petite partie de slam tous les
deux mois vous posant des questions et
vous y répondant vous relevez le défi
vous aviez dit oui se parler dans les
règles allez on y va on est d'accord
jour soit libérale dollar ban entendu le
nom scientifique du cerisier au monsieur
de minuscules crevettes monsieur
qu'attendent aujourd'hui la paire albert
albert oui et ce qui se passe bah je
fais des plantes qui vous êtes vous avez
pu l'autoriser ou pas pourquoi vous y
connaissez vous bah oui mais c'est cool
the series et j'ai fait les serres asus
monsieur le ceras us
c'est une plante qu'il faut tailler
entre 18 heures et 20 heures uniquement
massom batoche travers le nom
scientifique du cerisier cyril serait
pas le ser asus m'étonnant oui on était
devant un café on avait était tombé par
hasard sur un passant qui avait un amour
à tee shirts rappelle antoine kimathi
cher paddle stade français il passe à
lille et nice un papa dole de survie
panel tennis tant est que vous avez
défié encore un qui zecca use et
l'arrogance du magasin il est fort
l'effort est donc du coup vous étiez
donné rendez vous samedi après on s'est
tous retrouvés samedi après midi au
stade français
[Musique]
un peu de chance et c'est grâce à manu
un shérif voilà qu'on a on a gagné qui a
été exceptionnel écrit une nouvelle page
encore les poils regardez j'ai fait une
petite coiffure pour toi wen a été fou
quoi j'ai des trous se laisse pousser tu
me regardes plus toi ô giguère benoît il
est très très chaud il m'a dit lui et
moi au paddle on est imbattable
ils datent en installer mais vous voulez
on est tous aux médias que trois
capteurs cyril on t'attend c'est dommage
t'es là bas ce week-end
et bien sûr je suis là parce que sur la
il ya eu des mères je viens pour toi
génial et gaëlle hamastan cela mais je
viens ce week end jour est une tannée
dix mois patrick tu fatwa de ouf là et
il ya tout le monde et il ya benoît
paire et attitudes passe hélas goffin et
hanouna il est où c'est une fan ou quoi
nl j'espère qu'il vient regarder là je
chatte là je charrie pas du tout là
benoît et maintenant les messieurs
samedi dimanche
non au contraire moi je moi je vais te
coach et moi patrick dans la tête je
suis un des plus forts actuellement tu
le sais et c'est vrai que c'est très
laid plus longtemps mais paraît très
très longtemps c'est que c'est que de la
télé on s'en était par les mêmes avant à
prendre ou à laisser valérie on en a
parlé tous les deux exactement va
s'arrêter je peux me permettre
simplement à lévis d'embrasser très très
très fort d'avoir des équipes techniques
parce que c'est nous et hemani même
voilà mon travail et je vous embrasse
tous très fort les garçons et les filles
et on embrasse également la production
et tous mes chroniques et mon urine
dames ont fini non vraiment il emilie
lopez nussa role in fine sur la borne
soit pas tous les citer mais je vous
embrasse très très fort et merci à tous
a été spectateur mais 5e chroniqueur
leur finale je suis accablé c'est les
règles du shopping il ya une candidate
marie qui a retenu mon attention
devant le look d'une autre personne a
été hyper sympa à la fais des
compliments mais elle a pas vraiment le
même discours une fois qu'elle se
retrouve seul faire devant un duo assez
génial et derrière
la fracasse ça me rappelle quelqu'un ici
autour de la table bernard et
d'encercler plusieurs critères la bande
à vous avez décidé de me chambrer
d'accord match c'est que ce soit bernard
mais tu as très sympathique pour autant
les bras les rides du public ce qui pour
vous le plus bas bernard le mot que tu
dis toi je pense que c'est qu'au vide
qu'on veut plus on en veux pas du tout
c'est qu'on est la bière ne s'achète
mais vous vous êtes devenu très démago
lui alors être élu c'est un truc de ouf
et imago à peine à choisir ce que j'ai
dit que je change hélas la méthode avant
ça fait 2 diatta l'engin reconnais parle
aux rémois qui vont des des fruits et
légumes qu'ils souhaitaient des délais
allez dd des aubergines non mais c'est
vrai c'est le raymond qui pue des pieds
qu'on veut nous c'est pas plus la cepal
remo qui met du al jarreau sur ces
doyens pas d'accord non
et voilà alors vous avez vu la danse
sexy donc c'est simple car à l'etivaz
grille à les y ait laissé pas mal d'un
délire attention c'est parti on démarre
par le premier chroniqueur je ne sais
pas qui va arriver c'est parti lors donc
ça pue sexy on y va mais c'est pas mal
c'est parce au sud il est beau gosse il
est beau gosse et moi doit être regardée
dans ces cas là mes joueurs et mes
heures ouais 2e 2e chroniqueur l'élégant
l'élégant la caméra pour chaque
chroniqueur
oh
c'est drôle la publicité à l'intérieur
la mer
pourquoi les yeux fermés
[Musique]
et puis 10 la salle en remercie
à l'issue de leur beau c'est parti et
l'a fait
[Musique]
hu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
bizarrement les deux meilleures
interventions ce sont les personnes qui
sont les plus gérable et la grande
question des possibles la place de
l'ormeau
c'est là que c'était bien champs dans
deux mois en fait
[Applaudissements]
bravo je ne t'aime pas non plus à
l'audience ça va pas tu es pas été
terrible
alors je viens directement maxi 7,9
[Rires]
magali c'est mon avenir c'est une
téléspectatrice les bagatelles
c'est des gros bisous magali stéphane
smagghe à liège est génial